Eğer bu iki garip konusu Aslında bu
arada ismini vermeden fakat çok önemli
kullandığım bir başlık Çünkü Tutku
hakikaten benim hayatımın işlerimin
vazgeçilmez bir parçası Çok iddialı bir
kavram Çünkü hayatımın anlamı ya da
yaşama sebebi diyoruz bunu kaçımız bulur
kaçımız bulmaz yani gerçekten altı
doldurulması gereken vitamin Benim iki
gayri kavramı ile karşılaşmam tanışmam
üç dört sene önce kitabını eline
geçmesiyle oldu ve bir solukta okudum
aslında olan bütün hayatım değişti diye
lafa girebilirim ama aslında öyle olmadı
birazdan farklı oldu bende çünkü ay
kavramının tanıyınca öğrenince dedim ki
acaba Ben ben iki gaybı bulmuş olabilir
miyim hiç böyle düşünmemiştim
bakmamıştım neden derseniz Çünkü bir
takılanlar aklıma geldi ya da kendi
hayatından o kadar bir takım karakter
özellikleri ki bunlardan bir kısmı ve
saplantı ve takıntı derecesinde
olabiliyor Enes abi örnek vereyim Belki
çok daha iyi anlatacağım O zaman
kendimize ben 21 yaşında bir oğlum var
Ona hamile olduğum zaman sezeryanla
alacaklarını söylediler tabi bu
ameliyathaneye girmek Demek benim de ilk
ameliyathane deneyimi bir de şunu
biliyorum o hastanenin ameliyatı
annesinin yeni dekore ettim neyse beni
sevdiğini soktu aramaya tane ve
doktorlar bir kişi var işte öyle
başlıyorlar Ben de bir Yandım
ameliyathaneye çek ediyorum yani
köşesine bakıyorum renklerine bakıyorum
malzemesini bakıyorum yapmaları
bakıyorum diyor ki Bakarsın bir daha
giremezsin Bu sistemin olan anne
görebiliyorsan gör orada Uzaktan bir ses
duydum Doktorum Bana en üstü sevgiliye
Biz diyor sana koz verdik ama sen
direniyorsun bayılmamak için ya korkma
Az bırak kendini ben onu kendimi
Bıraktım hastaları korku değil ben
tamamıyle şeye odaklanma Bu bir taraftan
doğum gibi bir önemli bir şeyin
içindeyim bu aslında meclisteki de forma
girersiniz kızımı dersiniz bazı
arkadaşlarımı anlattığım zaman tabii ki
bana dediler kendi sen biraz değişik bir
tipsin
gerçekten de birçok sunumu başladığım
gibi ben rahatlıkla söyleyebilirim ki
ben çok tutkulu bir tasarımcı ve bir İç
mimarım Mesleğimi aşığım ve bazen
özellikle mesleğim git ile ilgili
konularda zaman mekan kişi yemek su her
şeyi unutabiliyorum ve yakın çevrende
bundan gerçekten muzları Kendimi Bildim
Bileli böyleyim yani bir şey yapıyorsam
gerçekten içinde çok fazla kayboluyorum
ve mesleğin benim için bir para
kazanılan bir aktivite değil tasarımı
çok seviyorum Artık benim hayatımın bir
parçası onun içinde iki gayet başlığın
altında biraz kendinden bahsederek tabi
gideceğim eşi
18.25 senedir kendi kurduğumuz
hiç yani ofiste iç mimarlık ve ürün
tasarımı kol kola götürüyoruz O da benim
gibi tutkulu şanslıyım Hakikaten de bir
noktadan sonra belki hem işe hem ortak
olmamız vesilesiyle bizim ev ofis işte
hobi iş hepsi birbirine karışmış durumda
eğer bundan çok şikayetçi değilim
aslında bunun yok şimdi de yaşıyoruz
senelerdir o anlamda çok üretken
olabiliyoruz
Burada iki baybaşın altında Aslında
altını çizmek istediğim konu sizin
birtakım değerleriniz var yani
hobileriniz Allah hayatı bir bakış
açınız var
Bartu tutkularımız var ama bunları
Aslında birbirinden çok da farklı şeyler
değil bunlar yememiz uzantısı ve Tutku
dediğimiz şey de asla bütün bu
uzantıları birbirine uyum içerisinde
bağlayan dikkat ediyor ya bu istediğin
zaman genç arkadaşların aklına şöyle
birşey beliriyor olabilir ya Ne kadar
uzun bir süre yani insan canı sıkılmaz
yine mesleği yapmaktan ben çok
rahatlıkla şunu söyleyebilirim ki
önümüze Her yeni proje konduğunda Sanki
o işe yeni başlıyor muşum gibi iştahla
ve heyecanla çocuk gibi o yeni projeye
başlayacak biliyorum bunlar bana tabi
çok enteresan girdi bu kavramı çok da
okuyup öğrenmeden önce birazcık diyor ve
devlet gibi gördüm ben bunu hiçbir
kaybetmeyeceğim bu amatörlüğü hiçbir
büyümeyeceğim Evet bu yeni malzemeler
yeni üretim biçimlerini falan
barındırıyor sa İnanılmaz bir şekilde
bir heyecan duyuyorum Çünkü aslında
tasarım olayı sıkıldığınızda İzin
vermeyen durağın olmayan meslek
ve en güzeli de aslında kendi açından
baktığım zaman gerek yetiştirilme
şeklinden gerek Bulunduğunuz lokasyondan
kültürümüzden karakterinizden resimden
Kargo Ya aslında Siz çok fazla şeyi
forma aktara biliyorsunuz tasarımda Yani
bu sadece alıp malzemeyi bir form verme
işi değil arkasında Ciddi bir anlam
yatıyor yani diğer mi değişti düşündüğüm
zaman ben hayallerimi söylemleri ve
aslında bir forma dönüştürüyor böyle bir
form gibi o bir obje oluyor birisi
tarafından kullanılıyor Soralım mı acaba
Benim iki gayet Ne yani ben bunu
Bulabildin mi acaba böyle sorduğum zaman
şöyle düşünüyorum hayallerimin formaline
dönüştürebilmek bunu ellerimde
yapabilirim Çok tutkulu olduğum
renklerle malzemelerle
dokularla çizim yaparak bazen
Türkiye'nin
yapamayacağım artık Lara Türklerle
işbirliği yaparak Aslında yaptığınız şey
hayallerimizi Bir forma haline
dönüştürmek ama bunu yaparken de aynı
bir çamur oynar gibi siz Aslında bu
harcadığınız zamanı bir faydaya
dönüştürüyoruz Çünkü bu bir obje oluyor
iki tarafından kullanılmaya başlıyor
Şimdi burada hemen sizin yaşlarınız a
inip o Mesleğimi seçtiğim güne dönmek
istiyorum belki Hani bir empatide olur
Çünkü Eminim bu yaşta birçoğunuzun
aklında hakketten endişeler var Ne
yapacağız bundan sonra mesleğimiz ne
olacak bütün hayatımız boyunca
yapacağınız şey mi olacak gibi bunu
Aslında Siz yaşlarda meslek seçimi
yapmak için kaybolmuş ve kendi ve
daralmış hissettiğim zamanda çok yakın
bir aile dostumuz bana şu düğünü soruyu
sordu Dedi ki seni TC Zeynep abla burada
ismini de alayım Benim ablama dedi gece
gel oturalım Sen bana bir söyle dedi
Mesela dedi sabaha kadar bir şey yapmak
zorundasın Bu okulda veya işin de
seninle mutlu eder diye sordu o zaman
iki galiba falan yok yani kavram kitap
hiçbir şeyden haberimiz yok ama o büyük
kelimeyi sordu kullandım ne mutlu
edersin da aynı benden doktorluk işletme
bir sürü şey bekliyor hiçbirini Hayal
edemiyorum kendini yaparken dedim sabaha
kadar çizim yapalım şimdi yapamaması
sanatçı olabileceğini de hissediyorum
dedi ki bak gece şöyle bir şey var
meslek var Her bir objeyi hayatındaki
Sen yeniden değerlendirip Ondaki
problemleri bugünden tasarlayabilirsiniz
beslenme aşık oldum ve o bölüme girmek
istediğimden gelen her şeyi yaptım şey
var bu O anlık bir şey mi Hayır bu Aslı
devam eden bir süreç ondan sonrası Çok
önemli çünkü bu hikaye hiç Bulutsuzluk
yok var bir sürü engel var her şey var
Önemli olan işte aşkı aslında aynı şeyde
tutabilmek koşullar değişiyor koşulların
hepsini yönetemiyorsunuz
yönetebileceğiniz var yönetemediniz bile
basit değiştiriyorsunuz Dolayısıyla
acaba bulaşması aynı kalacak bu bir
günlük bir anlık bir karar mı bunun
böyle olmadığına dair Biz birazdan
örnekler Vereceğim tabii ki annemi
düşünün Mesela yani bir sürü kurduğunuz
düzen bir anda bir gecede iki girişi de
değil gitti ve biz Uzunca bir süre bunun
içine girdik şimdi burada test etmek çok
kolay Rotayı değiştirmek çok kolay ama
bir şeyler size burada tutuyor Aslında
ben bunu biraz sunumlarını kullandığı
metaforlu anlatmaya çalışıyorum Bu düğme
da formuyla şimdi birimizin eline
diyelim ki böyle bir düğüm edilmiş ipler
veriyor ve sonrasında kullanmanız lazım
Bu benim önüme bu konduğu zaman ben bunu
çözene kadar olmasından kalkmam Yani bu
benim
saplantımı Dersiniz takıntımı dersiniz
yoksa iki gayet mi dersiniz size
bırakıyorum o düğüm çözülecek ve bu tip
saplantısı olan bir gök başlarsınız tam
yere varırsınız bir başka düz çıkar
Biraz daha ilerlerse bir başka büyük
projelerimize bakış açımız hep böyle
Yani biz problem çözmeyi seviyor beni Bu
vizyoner bakış açısı dediğimiz şey asla
girdiğini problem içerisine nereye
gittiğini bilmeden iyi ol alıyorsun
ve her seferinde soruyoruz kendimize biz
bir ürün tasarlıyor zaman acaba bunlar
kastı gerçekten çözümü bir problem var
mı dışarıda bu kadar uzun Varken biz
niye yenisini yapıyoruz şimdi bunu
anlatmamın sebebi şu Aslında buradaki bu
bu
takıntı veya buradaki bir fayda arayışı
bize hakikaten yolumuzdan çevirmeyen
rotadan çevirmeyen özellik
pandemi de olsa
Hatta çoğu zaman Krizlere denk geldik
defalarca ürünlerimiz yarıda kaldı bir
fikrimiz vardır mesai egzersiz Ali ile
ilgili altı sene sürün haline gelmesi
ama öyle bir anlar ki ben doktora gittim
fizik tedavi için doktorunuza doktor
sevgili doktorun ofisinde o aleti görüp
Onun hem hastalığı hem kendisini
kullanılmıyor Bana pozitif geribildirim
verdiği bu çok büyük bir haz İşte o
zaman sabrı sabrın ne kadar değerli
olduğunu anlıyorsunuz gayeyi ne döneyim
ve kendi bu tip şeyleri diğer adamlarını
çok görüyorsunuz Ben de bunu bize göre
Siz çizdim geriye baktığım zaman
yazışıp
sanırım yüzü aşkım kullanılan ürünümüz
var dışarıda bir kısmını paylaştım
sizinle sıkmamak için bir kısmı
beklemede bir kısmı alternatif olarak
sunulmuş yani İki Yüzü buluyor çok
sevdiğiniz Aşık olduğunuz bir şey
yapıyorsunuz İyi olduğunuzu düşündüğünüz
bir şekilde yapıyorsunuz ve objelere
dönüşüyor sayfaya dönüşü Dışarıda
insanlar Bunları kullanabiliyor bunun
verdiği haz İşte o bizim kazandığımız
yani güzü yolda iten izne sürekli
engelli olduğumu sıkıntı yok Mutsuzluk
yok mu hepsi var ama sizi süreç
içerisinde sıkılmadan Aslında bu
engelleri Aşk meleğim Ne içiyorsunuz
Çünkü o anlamı uykusuz yani o sürecin
içerisinde mutlusunuz sonuçtan çok
yaptığınız işi odaklandığın için biz de
biraz böyle olayım diyebilirsiniz
gelecek O zaman sen mesleğini bulduğun
gün Nestle karar verdiğin hayatın
anlamını da Buldun mu Çubuk bu
anlattıklarından bu çıkıyor olabilir mi
Bunu da internette çok sık gördüm Bu
cümleyle biraz açıklamak istiyorum
Artvin'de atfedilmiş ama sıkıntı yok
cümle şu hayatınızdaki en önemli iki gün
iki gün var Ve bunu bir tanesi
doğduğunuz gün İkincisi de neden
doğduğumuz Al
şimdi anlattıklarım biraz bunu destekler
gibi ama değil ben bu ikinci önemli gün
var ya hani o hayatımızın anlamını
keşfettiğiniz gün ben bunu bir gün
olduğuna inanmıyorum Aslında bu Uzunca
bir süreç bu ve keşif süreci bir
yolculuk o gün bir karar veriyorsunuz
Ama hayat çok uzun değil O çok dediğim
gibi sizde yaşıyorsunuz çevreniz
değişiyor O süreç içerisinde acaba Siz
bunun nasıl geliştiriyorsunuz nasıl
değerlendiriyorsun herkes tasarımcı
olmayı seçiyor ama benim yolum ayrı bir
başkasının yolu ayrı veya bir sürü
meslek var böyle onun için aslında bunun
Tekin olduğu fikrine kesinlikle karşıyım
bu hakikaten tüm hayatını yayılması
gereken bir süreç Yani bu kendimizi
arama anlamı bulma bu süreç zaten Eğer
bir günü arıyorsak bütün hayatımız onu
aramakla geçirip mutsuz olabiliriz Bu
yanılgıya düşmemek lazım
şimdi hemen de ki gayet kelimesine
tekrar geri dönüyorum Evet iki hayat
demek gayet içi baktığınız zaman
Japonca'da etki hayatın sebebi veya
yararı anlamı diye geçiyor ama bir
kelime daha var akış hayatın akışı ben
bu kelimeyi çok seviyorum açıkçası Çünkü
akışını ve başı var Ne sorunu var
Bu bir süre dik ve
ve hakikaten şanslıysanız önünüzde uzun
ya ne yaparsa bu süreci dolu dolu
faydaya dönüştürmek yaşamak Aslında
sizin elinizde ama herkesin çıkış yolu
farklı çünkü biz farklıyız
farklılıklarımız var güzel tarafı da o
yani sizin bu akış içerisindeki
hayatınız ona başlayış şekliniz Belki de
yürüdüğünüz koştuğumuz anlardan itibaren
başlıyor Bu akış Biricik bir akış yani
size özel işin en güzel tarafı Yani
farklı bir ailenin içine duyuyorsunuz
belli bir lokasyonu da uyuyorsunuz
mutlaka aileniz sizin karakteriniz ile
takılmış Ellerden sonra Aslım Siz üstüne
katmaya başlıyorsunuz ve bir su süreç
keyifli mi sürecek keyfi de olmalı zaten
ve boksun içerisinde aldığınız yaşta
evlenen
hayatımıza ekledikleri hayatımızdan
çıkardıkları Bunlar kişilerde olan ama
hepsi bir arada Aslı senin bu akışınızı
etkiler hale geliyor Bu anlamda önce
bütün hayata yayılıyor Burada gerçekten
kritik olan nokta
da anda gerçekten Maximum kalarak O ana
olabilen en iyi şekilde en verimli
şekilde değerlendirebilmek Bazen bu
sevmediğiniz bir ders olabilir
Ben buna da inanıyorum öğrenilen edilen
her bilginin her tecrübenin Eğer
tutkuyla o anda kalarak yapılıyorsa
kesinlikle sizin büyük amacınıza sizin
itekleyen ufak ufak kadınlar olduğunu
düşünüyorum o yüzden çok hobi edinilmesi
önerilir Hele ki sizler Bu kavramla
bizden çok erken Tanıştığımıza göre
Benimde tavsiyem olabildiğince kendinizi
sorgulamanız meraklarını zaky İnşallah
biz de bir daha fazla bela
bitkilerde bunları bir pota birleştirmek
de mümkün yaratıcılığın temelinde de bu
arasında farklı bir sürü merakımızı da
olabilir trip çok yaratıcı bir tasarım
yolunuz şart değil her meslekte bu yükün
Yani bu süreç biraz Aslında adanmışlıkla
ilgili herşey için de bulduk her şeyi
iştahla yapmanızı tavsiye ediyorum Çok
da fazla öğüt vermek istemiyorum
Bilmiyorum ki de genç yaş grubu öyle
ölçü sevmez bugün Aslında ben ben sular
benim için çok etkilidir Kendi
katıldıkları bazen bir kelime ya da bir
cümle benim hayatımın akışına anlam
katabilir arzu ediyorum ki inşallah
Benim de sunum şeklim böyle birşeye
dönüşür ve bugün asla bu sonradan
aklınıza şöyle bir şey kalarak
ayrılmanızı hayal ediyorum
hayatımızın anlamını bulma kendini
tanıma süreci
anlık bir karar değil Lütfen
rahatlayın Mesleğinizi seçerken Sakin
bir şekilde hakikaten kendinize sorun
acaba mutlu olabileceğim şeyler neler
olabilir ya bu kadar bugün verildi
değişmeyecek diye bir şey yok Hayat size
pek çok farklı imkansız alabilir miyim
olan o imkanları beğeniyorsunuz beğen
bir sus bip şekilde avantajı çevirme ki
pek çok tanıtım ve sonunda Bunların
örneklerinde aslında dinlediniz
yani Yaşanan her an aslında iki gayeniz
e katkısı olan bir an bunun bilincine
varmak durumundayız bu niye bu kadar
önemli Çünkü siz mutlu olarak bir iş
yaptınız da çok daha verimli çok daha
üretken oluyorsunuz ben birazcık belki
aslında kendi hayatımdan örnek vererek
bunun altını çizmek istedim üretken
olmak benim hayat amacım Yani gerçekten
Kendimi üretmeden düşünemiyorum burada
bir küçük örnek daha vererek Aslında
sunuma sonlandırmaya çalışacağım şu anda
Örneğin nereden hatırladığımız
çıkaramadım sporcunun ismini hatırlayan
bu gerçek bir hikaye
koşucusu Olimpiyatları hazırlayan bir
antrenör rekor kıracağını biliyor Daha
önceden başarılıları var fakat
çalışmaları arası sırasını rekoru
Ulaşamıyorlar
belli bir noktadan sonra koşucusuna
diyor ki ya Tamam sen git bu piste
Kendini rahat bırak psikolojik şeylerden
kurtul Seslendi sayede sadece kendim
için hoş keyifle konuşmaz diye ölçü
yapmayacağım bugün ve Tabi ki tahmin
edeceğiniz üzerine gizli gizli konu
metreyi çalıştırıyor ve sporcusu o gün
rekoru kırıyor şimdi bu buradan anlatmak
istediğim şu gerçekten keyifle
yaptığınız zaman
ortaya çıkan sonuç mutlaka faydalı
olacaktır
rekor Benim umrumda değil bence sizin de
olmasın yani çok sonra kenetlenme yin bu
örneği verdim diye de hayatı böyle bilir
ya biz ANF yarışmaktan hiç hoşlanmam En
sevmediğim şeydir ama koşmak güzel yani
maraton güzel yani bir oyun ve boyun
sonu yok onun içerisinde yer keyif
aldığınız sürece koşuyorsun sağdan
soldan geçen ağacı gökyüzünü bunun
tadına alabiliyorsanız bunun faydaya
dönüşmesi mümkün değil bu noktada her
birinize şu anda göremiyorum
Gözlerinizin içine bakamıyorum ama ben
biliyorum ki Her birimizin potansiyeli
var o rekor sizin için her neyse hiç
önemli değil ve dışarıda çözüm bekleyen
o kadar çok problem var ki her iki bu
dönemlerden geçtikten sonra hangi
kulları Seçtiğiniz hiç önemli değil
hangi mesleği yöneldiğimiz bence
hepinizin yazacak hikayeleri var Ben
güveniyorum Bu anlamda da biraz böyle
Cesur
be hakikaten biraz gözlemci biraz
meraklı olmanızı tavsiye ediyorum ve
Hepinize bol şans diliyorum bugünlük
Benden bu kadar